bon bah on des autres d'où là on va
passer aux trois questions qui tuent
alors ok tu maintenant alors quoi
d'abord excuse c'est vrai que la saison
prochaine tu seras plus sur ces 8 et 4
sur un peu surpris une réponse de file à
jean-michel bien un les féroé
frérot base il te plaît mettez mais
alors mettez boulette sur la table alors
[Rires]
alors je sais pas d'où tu tiens cette
info ce qui se dit mais il se dit que je
serai plus sur ces 8 l'année prochaine
ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que quoi
qu'il arrive je serai dans le groupe
canal l'année prochaine quoiqu'il arrive
puisque je suis encore trois ans encore
en contrat avec le groupe canal+
donc quoi qu'il arrive je serai dans le
groupe canal+ et les prochaines et voilà
normalement sur ces 8 à priori mais
voilà non à venir en tout cas je serai
dans le groupe canal encore pour trois
ans ce qui est sûr et certain donc voila
tu vas voir sur le dos encore trois ans
oui nico a perdu 10 normalement
bah oui c'est incroyable normalement
tout peut arriver sur ses imitations %
c'est sûr point barre tout peut arriver
pourquoi vous dites le groupe canal est
passé vite
tout peut arriver je peux montrer
quelques y compris une montée en
puissance hors antenne
c'est à dire où ça bas
dirigeants postes à responsabilité je
serai encore à l'antenne pour trois ans
ça c'est sûr et certain il ya d'autres
chaînes
déjà je me régale avec les
téléspectateurs avec vous aussi et voilà
mais on sait voilà où en devenir 305 of
à la rentrée en access d'accord ça mais
c'est sûr on axé sur ces 8 mais vous
êtes là 626 normalement ce sera sur ses
mythes mais on sait vraiment mais on
sait jamais en tout cas je serai dans le
groupe canal voilà